Uh, what I want to do this
morning is first of all,
begin by recapitulating a couple
of points that we made last time.
Uh, you'll recognize our friend here, um,
having her blood feast.
And last time we talked about
the importance of malaria
in human history for a
little bit from ancient times
to the contemporary world.
And we tried to suggest that malaria
contingent to impose an extraordinary
burden of suffering and death.
And along with those consequences
that follow and it's trained poverty,
low productivity illiteracy,
a low level of political,
social and educational participation.
We also talked does,
you'll remember about the transmission
of the disease with the complex life
cycle of plasmodium and an
awfully lean mosquitoes.
We talked about the effect of the disease
on the human body of the patient and
the symptoms that result from malaria.
And we tried to deal also with the great
years of discovery at the end of the
1890s between 1898 and 1901 when the
great mysteries of this disease or largely
unraveled in two different places.
First in India with the collaboration
of Ronald Ross and Patrick Manson,
they demonstrated the
mosquito of transmission of
malaria with regard to avian
malaria that is among birds.
And then the other place where the,
um,
even more importantly was Italy,
where Giovanni Battista Grassy and other
scientists have what was called the
Italian school or the room school proved
the mosquito theory of transmission for
human beings.
And I hope that in that discussion it was
apparent to all of you that malaria is
by far the most complex of
all the diseases that we've
studied or we'll study in
our course and not points important and
underlies the fact that we spent a lot
of time talking about the
complexity of the disease.
It's important because it helps us to
understand a great deal of the history.
One point is that if we understand that
we're in a position to understand also
why research on malaria generated such
intense intellectual excitement and the
1890s it was then that malaria ology
became the center piece for the medical
discipline of tropical medicine here.
What's one of the world's most oldest and
most important public health problems?
And suddenly it was yielding at secrets.
There was a tremendous excitement
intellectually and malaria.
Ology attracted some of the world's
leading scientists and public health
officials.
We also wanted to talk about
the complexity of malaria
because a second reason
is that it helps us to understand why
the public health strategies that we've
examined so far haven't worked
in dealing with malaria.
If we think, for example,
what are the main, uh,
public health strategies
that we've discussed so far?
One was plagued measures, you
know, the drill by now, sanitary,
cordons, quarantines, isolation.
These however,
proved to be powerless against a disease
that's born by vectors as efficient and
mobile as an awfully mosquitoes and
high malarial and Dennis city areas.
Mosquitoes are infinitely numerous and
infinitely mobile plagued measures would
be no help at all.
We can understand also why another
form of public health was useless.
The sanitary movement was irrelevant.
Malaria is not like cholera.
It's not a disease of filth or
the bacteria that thrive in it.
Places that are immaculately clean can
be lethally infested with mosquitoes and
the plasmodium that they bear.
Furthermore,
malaria is a disease of rural areas.
Primarily an urban cleanups
where therefore largely
irrelevant in combating it.
So a second strategy of public health
that we've confronted so far was powerless
in dealing with this disease.
Another public health strategy that
we've examined was the strategy of
vaccination and we've seen that pioneered
by Edward Jenner and developed much
more by Louie Pastor.
And this to thus far has proved
unavailing with regard to malaria.
Let's think for a moment about vaccines,
and I'd like to argue that
they're effective primarily
under certain conditions,
that they aren't universal
panaceas for all diseases.
They're helpful primarily,
first of all,
in combating diseases against the body
develops a robust acquired immunity.
Smallpox is a perfect example.
A patient who has once suffered from
smallpox but then recovers is then immune
for the rest of his or her life.
And so the strategy for vaccination
is to produce artificially the same
effective immune response that was
generated by the naturally occurring
infection.
The strategy then is to reproduce
what nature does on her own.
But in malaria,
the immune response of the body is limited
and it takes multiple infections and
recovery there from to inquire a partial
immunity. And that immunity
even then is short lived.
It's partial and short lived.
If you have painfully acquired
an immunity for malaria,
and then you move away from the
malarial area in a couple of years,
your immunity, uh, fades away.
And if you return to the malarial area,
you're susceptible all over again.
So that's,
this is one factor that
makes vaccine development.
So very complicated.
Another point about sin about vaccine
development is not vaccines haven't so far
been developed against a pathogen with
the lifecycle as complex as that of a
plasmodium
and targeting a virus or bacterium.
A vaccine is always dealing quite
simply with the virus or the bacteria.
But the point about studying,
one of the points about investigating
the lifecycle of the plasmodium is that
they're different.
They go through a series
of complicated life stages.
Sometimes they're sporozoites,
sometimes they're marazonal ice,
sometimes they're gametocytes.
And the problem with the vaccine
is that in order to be viable,
it has to be effective against all of
those phases in the life cycle of the
plasmodium.
And then also another feature as I said,
is that malaria is not a single disease.
It's a family of four
different parasitic diseases.
And the vaccine has to be
effective against not simply one,
but against numerous therefore,
um,
species of parasite.
Now,
I don't want to argue that therefore
the development of a vaccine against
malaria is impossible. In
fact, as we're speaking,
scientists are hard at work
trying to develop such a vaccine.
And indeed they have come
up with one the most sick.
You read some rather
silly things in the press.
The vaccine developers came up with
a vaccine in the last few years.
That's about 30% effective.
Uh,
I remember reading in places like
The New York Times that malaria would
therefore be eradicated
globally in five to seven years.
This sort of rather silly prediction.
And even the people I know because I've
talked to them who are developing the
vaccine,
have no such illusion about its efficacy.
They're thrilled because
it's 30% effective,
but that means that it's
70% not effective. Well,
in order to understand the evolution of
public health strategies against malaria
and the problem facing the world
today in dealing with this disease,
then we need to note that the
very complexity of malaria
has led to a wide array
of different strategies to combat it as
well as to an ongoing debate on which
course is likely to be most effective
and does yet there's no consensus in the
international health community on the
best and most effective strategy despite
the fact that since the turn of
the 20th century at the least,
malaria is a disease paradoxically that
has such extraordinary ravages on the
global population.
And yet paradoxically it's a disease
that's both treatable and preventable.
There is an amazing paradox this morning.
Then I want to talk about not the effects,
uh,
the nature of the plasma Modia
the nature of mosquitoes,
the life cycle or
symptomatology of malaria.
But I'd like to look instead
at the disease from the
societal point of view and
in particular on efforts to develop
a successful anti-mullerian strategy.
But developing a strategy or thinking
about the proper strategy against malaria
is easier if we think of a number of
how ways in which this disease might be
characterized,
the ways in which it has been
seen by leading scientists,
physicians and public health
officials who've dealt with it.
So I'm
wondering if we could think of malaria,
we might ask a number
of questions about it.
How should we describe this disease?
Is it a disease of poverty?
And what's the evidence for that that
would entail dealing with an a particular
way that might be different
from other ways? Is it a,
and one of the leading World Malaria
Ologists in the early 20th century defined
malaria as a house disease?
In other words,
it's primarily defined by poor housing
conditions in which people are crowded,
uh, in order to work in
agricultural occupations.
And those houses are porous to insects
and it's in the House that the disease is
transmitted and both mosquitoes
and human beings are infected,
or should we see it instead
as an occupational disease.
We've talked about the relationship of
malaria to agriculture and it's quite
clear that certain forms of agricultural
production create and generate high
risk for those who practice them and
malaria is contracted overwhelmingly by
people who work in fields under
certain conditions or should we?
Another way of thinking about it is,
and not case,
one way of attacking a malaria then
would be to have occupational improve the
conditions of farming of agriculture to
regulate rice fields and all the rest of
it. That would be what you
would do perhaps if you
define it as an occupational
disease,
should we think of it instead
as an environmental disease,
that it's a disease that flourishes work.
The environment has been degraded
where there's been deforestation,
for example,
where the hydrology of
rivers has been undermined,
where there's flooding of places where
there are swamps and impounded water.
In that case,
the way of dealing with malaria you might
think might be to have land drainage
reclamation,
environmental sanitation,
quite a different strategy
for dealing with the disease.
What should we call this
particular disease is in an
endemic disease or is it an
epidemic disease?
And here.
I think that the malaria is one of those
diseases that we're studying in our
course.
That's actually both.
That is to say in a particular locality,
it is an endemic disease.
Uh,
for example,
if you were to go to the
tropical areas of Africa today,
malaria is present throughout the year.
It's highly even hyper endemic,
but it's also capable of
being an epidemic disease.
First of all,
that's easiest to see perhaps in temperate
zones where malaria has also been
prevalent because then it's seasonal
and you have the winter when,
uh, the diseases, it's too cold for
the plasmodium to be transmitted,
but you have an annual summer epidemic.
But in addition,
under certain conditions,
we would say that the epidemic
is intensified in conditions,
for example,
of years of exceptionally
heavy rainfall or uh,
in say in tropical Africa,
it becomes an epidemic disease when
something happens to the environment.
When there are complex emergencies like
warfare that cause or famine that causes
people to move in large numbers from
who or unlock immunity to move to areas
where the disease is prevalent.
So malaria can cause extraordinarily
intense epidemics against a background of
being also an endemic disease.
So I would like to argue and I will be
arguing in a moment that part of the
complexity of malaria and if
I were asked the question,
although you may want to disagree with
me because people are still arguing about
how one defines a malaria
and how one deals with it,
but I'd like to suggest that
perhaps it's all of those.
It's a disease of poverty.
This is part of its complexity,
its biological,
social and environmental complexity.
It is a disease of poverty.
It's also a house disease.
It's an occupational disease,
it's an environmental disease,
it's an endemic disease and it's
an epidemic disease as well.
Well,
what are the kinds of strategies that
have been deployed against this dreadful
disease?
One was since we now know that
it's transmitted by vectors,
Ronald Ross who was one of the
people who won the Nobel prize,
in fact for establishing that
very idea developed very quickly.
The idea then if it's a disease that's
caused that soprano admitted by vectors,
perhaps the right course for dealing
with malaria is vector control,
kill mosquitoes by insecticides or
remove their breeding grounds by
environmental sanitation,
by dealing with an unregulated
hydrology of an area by land drainage,
by removing, um, uncovered water.
A different strategy would be to deal
with not the mosquito but with the
plasmodium.
And so there have been,
and here I've talked about the Italian
School of Malaria Ologie and Giovanni
Battista Ganassi um,
had the idea that you would be able to
eradicate malaria by the use of anti
plasmodium, uh, that is Quinine,
one of the first effective magic bullets.
He thought the idea was that if we know
what causes malaria and we're is an
effective treatment for it,
if you can use it prophylactically to
prevent people from being infected for a
number of seasons in a
particular geographical area,
or if you can destroy the plasmodium,
the bloodstreams of all of the sufferers,
then you can prevent mosquitoes from
being infected for the following year.
And if you do that for several seasons,
then you could break the cycle of
transmission and eradicate malaria.
And both of the people who discovered
the mosquito theory of transmission very
quickly came to the idea
of malarial eradication.
Ross did so and Grossey immediately
thought that malaria had what he called,
um, feet. It was the
colossus with feet of clay.
And that ply nine would be the instrument
that would enable the world to around
a kid.
But if you think of it
as a disease of poverty,
you might think instead and a disease
of housing and an occupational disease,
then you might think of a different
strategy of social uplift.
That what you need to do to deal with
malaria is to practice social medicine,
to deal with poor diet,
poor wages,
child labor,
um,
those whole series of
complex factors that have,
that create the substratum
in which malaria thrives.
And then there is another
strategy which is quite common.
Uh, Lee thought of it has
not made much progress,
at least today. So who knows,
maybe it will in the future.
And that's the gender postural Ian
Strategy of hoping to develop an effective
anti malarial vaccine.
So a vaccine development is one of the
great hopes in the anti malarial struggle
and um,
enormous amounts of resources
are being invested in Vacs,
anti malarial vaccine
development as we speak.
Well, I want to give an
example of a particular place.
It's the one you're reading
about this week. Um,
which was the impact of malaria
on a particular country.
And I've chosen Italy
for particular reasons.
One is not, Italy had a special
relationship to malaria.
It was the only European western European
country where it wasn't a colonial
issue,
but rather the most important
domestic public health problem.
It was also the international center of
Malaria Ology from about 1900 and till
the Second World War.
In other words,
we've talked about the hegemony of Paris
in international medicine in the early
19th century,
down to the middle of the 19th century
in the smaller domain of malaria.
Ology Italy was the center of the
action from 1900 until World War Two.
This is the place where people went
to be trained in malaria ecology.
It was people traveled,
physicians from all over the
world to study with those who,
people who were called the Rome school
or the Italian School of malaria,
Ology Giovanni Battista Glossy,
most prominent,
but other names were extremely
prominent also like Angelo Chelsie.
And we could list a
whole series of others.
And it was Italians primarily who were
responsible for unraveling the mysteries
of malaria. Um, and finally,
Italy was a place that did
something quite extraordinary.
It was the first place to have a
successful strategy of anti-malarial
campaigning.
In other words,
a campaign began in 1900 and was
successful in eradicating malaria by 1962.
The last indigenous case of malaria
in Italy was in Sicily in 1962.
So this means that Italy has lessons and
there are not many places where there
have been campaigns that have succeeded
when intentionally in eradicating the
disease.
So this leads to a message of hope.
What can be accomplished by doing it.
And it also means that I think it's
useful to look at this successful campaign
in order to draw lessons from it.
But to be aware also of
the misuse of history,
because a lot of what I think are the
wrong lessons have also been drawn from
it. Well, in any case,
let's look just very,
very quickly at the Italian experience.
As you know,
Italy was United in the middle of the
19th century and by the 1880s they're what
they became the new rich liberal regime,
became aware of the prevalence of
the disease throughout the country.
And this is the map that was not the
best map artistically or even in terms of
clarity or I would even
say in terms of accuracy.
And so you're wondering why do I show
you this map of malaria in Italy when
they're actually better maps that
are more colorful and all the rest?
But this is for historians.
This is the important one because this
is the one that shook Italians up and
convinced them of the enormity
of the problem on their country.
And one of the things that's quite clear,
even in looking at this map is that
malaria was present everywhere.
Virtually. There are areas
that are yellow, pink,
and red of prominence or
extreme prominence, uh,
of malaria.
And it was the case also
that after unification,
instead of the problem unification seen
as a foundational moment for this new
regime that's supposed to deliver
economic betterment,
progress and also public health.
But instead the years at
the end of the 19th century,
see the malarial problem already intense,
getting worse,
worse because of things like
deforestation of the opera nines,
the railroad area era actually had a
devastating impact because it led to the
demand for trees to make the railroad
ties and the stations and all the rest and
therefore led to massive deforestation
and deregulation of the hydrology of the
entire peninsula,
which was turned topsy turvy.
It was also a time then of, um, uh,
of economic difficulties and crises
and malaria feeds on human misfortune.
And it did so in the late 19th
century. Well, in any case,
it'll be also provided. We've talked
about malaria as a housing disease.
I thought I'd just show you
a representative type of
peasant housing and even
down to the 1930s and forties.
And when you live in places
like this and a malarial area,
you're highly vulnerable be because this
is almost like being outdoors. In fact,
it's probably worse in terms
of mosquitoes. You're there.
It's entirely vulnerable
and open to flying in stacks
and having numerous people
sleeping in conditions like this,
uh,
helps to promote the disease
and transmission. Similarly,
we talked about it being an r uh,
an occupational disease.
It wasn't by chance that Italy is also
a place of rice fields and rice fields
are actually wonderful places for
mosquitoes and the rice workers were among
those people who are most vulnerable and
became symbolic as the victims of the
plasmodium. So in any case then, uh,
there was an epidemic and endemic
condition in Italy and Italy showed all of
those terrible consequences of
malaria that we've been talking about,
absenteeism in agriculture,
waste whole areas that weren't cultivated
because there were so dangerous and
those who did work on them sickened
and died an area of low productivity of
illiteracy,
the under development of civil society,
low participation in politics,
mass emigration.
And I would argue in deed that one of the
features of Italy is that we've talked
about north and south.
And I talked about agriculture being
a determinant of malaria and that the
global north had advanced forms of
agriculture that were intensive and not
conducive to malaria.
And the south,
the global south had the opposite.
Well,
this was reproduced in a microcosm in
Italy in that the north of Italy was much
less, uh, vulnerable to malaria.
And the form of malaria was
the milder via vacs, malaria,
while the south of Italy was riddled
with malaria and it was malaria that was
predominantly falciparum that is the
most devastating and lethal form of the
disease. Well, the,
there was a time of great scientific
discoveries that we've talked about.
Oh,
this is a famous picture just to show you,
this is a pick painting called malaria.
And as you see it sort of like a PA
ta or a deposition from the cross.
And I think it conveys a,
in a moving emotional way,
the reaction of a society to
intense malarial transmission.
Uh, this is the prime minister
at the turn of the century.
Until the first world war under whom
the malaria anti malarial campaign gets
started.
And this is Giovanni Battista Canarsie.
I tried to show him last time who was
the person who proves the mosquito
transmission, uh, among human beings.
The leading representative of the room,
School of Malaria Ology,
uh, and his work was, we've
talked about institutions.
This is the Santo speedy to hospital
where he conducted his research because
there were an enormous,
almost unending supply
of malarial patients.
And it was here that he first successfully
infected human beings with malaria,
with the number of scientific experiments
that you might consider ethically
problematic.
But in any case,
there weren't our rules about such things.
Um,
at the turn of the 20th century,
well,
the pillars of the eradication program,
the pillar of it was
initially going to be quinine.
And so Italy passed a series of Quinine
laws from 1900 to 1907 with support from
the liberal prime minister.
And the idea was that you could kill
the plasmodium break the cycle of
transmission and eradicate the disease.
Grosse seek thought it would be merely
a matter of a few years. In fact,
it then turned out to be impossible to
eradicate the disease so easily that
people were not used to
contact with physicians.
There weren't, uh, there, there
wasn't access, in other words,
to medical care distributing quinine,
which tremendously problematic.
It also has to be followed according to
a very complex regimen and it has to be
followed for months at a time.
And you can't get people to do that
unless they understand the disease.
And so it actually,
to have an effective anti
malarial program turned out,
you have also to deal with
poverty and with illiteracy,
which are the allies of the
mosquito and of malaria.
And so it was important to
teach people then it the,
a discipline of quinine
and the reasons for it.
So very quickly and,
and also health access was important.
And so new parts of the,
the program turned out to be,
um,
rural health stations.
It's expanding now beyond quinine
to include rural health stations,
education and rural schools.
In other words,
a whole plan plea of things that
we might call social medicine,
improved housing.
The actually Chelsie argues the trade
unions were powerful anti malarial tool
because they do help deliver better wages
and with that better diet and better
clothing and child labor laws.
And we know that children are particularly
susceptible to malaria and the
regulation of occupations that were
particularly dangerous such as working in
rice fields. Well, the results
of the liberal program,
which has expanded well
beyond distributing quinine.
And in other words,
it starts with the vision of a magic
bullet and moves very quickly to a whole
panoply of things that we
might for shorthand call
social uplift with have to do
with access to medical care,
improved housing,
civil liberties, education, um,
and all of those sorts of measures.
The results of the liberal program by
the eve of the first world war were a
massive decline in mortality at least,
but still the persistence of the
disease and then comes world war one,
which was an extraordinary
setback from malaria.
And I've talked about the way that
malaria is a disease that thrives on human
misfortune and there is no misfortune
that is better for malaria than war.
And I thought I would show you a few
paintings of the first world war to show
you the kinds of conditions that lead
in Italy that destroyed almost the first
15,
16 years of anti malarial efforts and
created this huge explosion of epidemic
malaria during the first world war.
And this is a famous painter,
US sartorial is his name who was a
competent and the first world war,
but then was wounded and returned
to the front as a painter.
I are rather as a
photographer. And he did, uh,
he took photographs of the conditions
at the fighting front and then he did
paintings for,
from his photographs.
And these are some of the most impressive,
I think moving pictures of the sorts
of conditions you can see exactly how
mosquitoes would thrive and
conditions of this sort. Um,
this is not dead soldiers,
these are soldiers
bivouacking after a battle.
And I think you can imagine them being
from non malarial areas and not having
resistance.
And you can see that they are a wonderful
feast for an awfully big mosquitoes.
And the soldiers from non malarial
areas felt sick and died in enormous
measures.
Or we've talked about malaria
as a housing disease will also,
the destruction of housing
renders people vulnerable.
If you have to move into tenths or
into the open fields to Bivouac,
to move from area to area,
from cities to the rural
areas and all the rest of it,
you'll become extraordinarily vulnerable
and saw the destruction of housing and
the housing stock was extremely important.
So there was this tremendous upsurge
of malaria during the first world war,
after the first World War in
1922 we have a new regime,
um, and this was the fascist
regime of Benito Mussolini.
We won't talk about the,
uh,
conditions that brought
Molly Salini to power,
but we now have a totalitarian
one party dictatorship,
the end of elections,
police, repression, violence,
the secret police and the foreign policy
of expansion to restore an umpire and
to pursue broad European
and African conquest.
By the end of the 1920s,
Mussolini is fully in power.
And he institutes some anti malarial
measures that became extremely famous and
he's often thought as the hero of the
Anti Malarial Movement because of what he
did in this area,
the Pontine Marsha's,
which is just outside of Rome.
And you'll be reading about that.
This was done however,
for political purposes more than for
medical ones because the point about the
pontine marshes was not only a couple of
thousand people live there in 1930 and
this became the height of the
regimes anti-mullerian measures,
which were to drain the swamps,
to build new housing
and to settle the land.
But it doesn't actually confront malaria
and the parts of Italy where the most
numerous people were
getting ill and dying.
It was an enormous propaganda
effort, uh, to show,
to demonstrate a more than health,
the power of the regime that
most Salini could succeed,
where liberals had failed,
where the pope's had failed and the
sorts of measures that were undertaken.
This is the kinds of
conditions that he found. Uh,
the swamps conditions,
I guess I'm overdoing it,
but I'm showing you there was plenty
of water and there were plenty of
mosquitoes.
And it was estimated that you had an
80% chance of contracting malaria if you
spent a single night in
this area in the summer, um,
before the drainage of the swamps.
Well,
this is the construction of something
modestly called the Mussolini can know.
And we'll see. Also when
pumping stations, land drainage,
you see canals being constructed,
what are being raised to be a harmlessly
diverted to the sea went with it as
well. The distribution of Quinine,
I'm showing quinine being distributed,
um,
education and literacy and the
teaching about the mosquito theory of
transmission. All of
that was important. Um,
there we see a fascist boy scouts learning
about larva and their collection and
taking that information home to their
families was part of the idea here where
they're doing the same thing.
Um, there were Sanatoria, um,
and you'll see the improved housing.
These are sturdy houses.
They have screened windows and all the
rest of it you'll see screens going up on.
So this was really a
huge, huge project. Uh,
it also included things that weren't so,
uh,
the building of new cities suddenly
then an area that was a swamp,
you see modern cities going up,
the display of power is enormous.
So this was really an,
uh,
idea that had as much to do
with the power of the regime,
uh,
as with public health.
So I'm not saying that it's my view that
fascism is in fact bad for your health
rather than good for it.
Um,
here are some of the propaganda pictures
of the first peasant of Italy here
among his smiling happy
crowds and all the rest of it.
So this was used in that way.
Well then part of fascism,
however,
you can't understand it without its
impetus to expansion and to war.
And the Second World War again led to,
um,
a major destruction,
uh, and to devastation,
repeating even a worse scale what had
happened during the first world war.
So I won't talk about that.
I won't talk either.
And this morning about a war crime that
I do discuss in the book that we'll see
the use of malaria as an
instrument of bioterrorism.
But my theme this morning is what are the
tools for dealing with malaria and the
lessons that can be learned.
And so I'd like to look then with the
downfall of fascism and another terrible
upsurge of malaria during
the Second World War,
there is a campaign to eradicate
malaria that gets underway,
1945,
1946 and succeeds by 1962 and
it's done with allied cooperation,
the leadership of, uh, with a, um,
of the Rockefeller Foundation
and money from this country.
And it involves the idea of that a
powerful new weapon to destroy mosquitoes,
a technological weapon, Ddt, uh,
was discovered during the war and is
now used as an instrument of powerful
insecticide, uh, to destroy malaria.
And this is thought in fact to be
and becomes a premise if we like.
The lesson is drawn that malaria was
eradicated in Italy after the use of DDT.
And so DDT is thought to be the
cause of the destruction of malaria,
the successful campaign.
And this becomes the premise
for an international campaign,
a global campaign of the World Health
Organization from 1955 until 1969 to use
DDT worldwide to eradicate
malaria globally.
And I want to argue that this is in fact
misleading because the wrong lessons
were drawn from what happened
in Italy and actual fact,
the eradication after World War Two was
possible in part because at Wa mark,
not only the use of DDT,
but it also meant a massive investment
of American aid to provide food,
clothing,
housing and employment that becomes first
UNRRA and then the Marshall aid plan.
And so there is an enormous campaign
to improve housing and conditions if
people, in other words, there's a
massive social uplift if we like,
that's going along at the
same time as the use of DDT.
At the same time,
you have the reestablishment of healthcare
services and rural health stations
and the massive distribution of quinine
and anti an artificial quinine developed
during the war,
outer brin and chloroquine.
So it's not a simple unit
dimensional program that succeeds.
Uh,
and so by 1962,
Italy becomes malaria free.
And I think that's one of the factors
that led to the possibility of the
economic miracle and it'll
becoming after by our day,
the world's seventh industrial power.
So there's an amazing measure of hope of
what can be done when you auratic Kate
Malaria, you unleashed productivity
and the and development.
But in addition,
this example then becomes the basis for
the post World War Two program of global
eradication that believed that it would
be possible simply to have a panacea,
a technological intervention with DDT.
And this is an experiment that
by 1969 collapses and failure.
And I would like to argue that this ought
to lead us to enormous questions about
today's anti malarial program of
the World Health Organization,
rollback malaria.
And very often it's thought that vaccine,
that the development of using some
sort of magic bullet would be adequate.
And I want to argue that this was partly
based on a misunderstanding of the
Italian lesson. And I think we're
dealing with in our own world,
the consequences of that
in the form now of, of,
uh,
either DDT or insecticide treated bed
nets as being the most useful instruments.
And I think the campaign is
having enormous difficulties.
And I think we need to think
about how we define this disease.
What are,
what is its substratum,
what conditions promoted and what kinds
of strategies are effective in combating
it.
So thank you.